[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
messbar war hellweg
freitagabend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch wo die zange für den sport
zahlreiche tore gleich schönen guten
abend und das sind einige unserer themen
heute
rückenwind für die meinungsfreiheit eine
philippinische journalistin und ein
russischer journalist erhalten den
friedensnobelpreis
der rückhalt bröckelt in österreich
halten die mitregierenden grünen kanzler
kurz für nicht mehr am 12
problemzone außengrenze die
eu-kommission untersucht berichte wonach
einige länder flüchtlinge brutal und zu
unrecht abweisen
der friedensnobelpreis in diesem jahr
ist eine überraschung und ein mächtiges
plädoyer für meinungsfreiheit als
voraussetzung für demokratie und
dauerhaften frieden ausgezeichnet werden
zwei journalisten die dafür ihr leben
riskieren die 58 jährige maria resser
von den philippinen und der 59 jährige
russe dimitri muratow und das sagt die
vorsitzende des nobel komitees
sie sind repräsentativ für alle
journalisten die für dieses ideal ein
stehen in einer welt in der demokratie
und meinungsfreiheit mit zunehmend
widrigen bedingungen konfrontiert sind
die vilbeler und ulf röller stellen die
beiden vor
maria resser klagt unermüdlich die
gewalt und korruption in ihrem land an
die philippinischen machthaber verfolgen
sie dafür nach einer gerichtsverhandlung
im märz sagt sie den einen satz der ihr
journalistisches leben zusammenfasst
last journalist in ruhe arbeiten
journalismus ist kein verbrechen
die nobelpreisträgerin ist die
mitbegründerin des online
nachrichtenportals keppler das
kritisiert immer wieder den anti drogen
krieg von präsident du tertre weil er
vor allem politische gegner jage wasser
warf dem autoritären regime deshalb
menschenrechtsverletzungen vor mehrfach
wurde sie wegen verleumdung verhaftet
die nobelpreisträgerin ist eine
kämpferin für einen journalismus der
sich auf fakten stützt
schon jetzt muss es noch nie so wichtig
gewesen heute aber es ist so schwer zu
berichten sind fakten sind sehr
langweilig aber trotzdem beginnt doch
alles damit dass wir die fakten
anerkennen
der nobelpreis für maria resser eine
ehrung im zeitalter von fake news
bei der zeitung die dimitrij muratow mit
gegründet hat und die er leitet gibt es
eine gedenkwand für sechs
journalistinnen der novaja gaseta die
ermordet wurden gestern jetzt sich der
todestag von anna politkowskaja deren
berichte über tschetschenien ihr
mächtige feinde einbrachte der mord
wurde nie ganz aufgeklärt mit dieser
riesigen machtmaschine 'ran
geheimpolizei agenten haben sie den
verantwortlichen nach 15 jahren immer
noch nicht gefunden das heißt es ist
kein zufall man kann mit journalisten
machen was man will der staat wird den
mörder decke
trotzdem ort trotz
einschüchterungsversuchen wie diesem
attentat mit einer giftigen substanz im
meer kurator zeitung bleibt unabhängig
als letzte russlands er selbst setzt
sich unermüdlich für die rechte
kritischer medien ein die geraten gerade
weiter unter druck
wir sehen dass der staat viele junge
medien und plattformen die sich auf
investigatives spezialisiert haben
brands mangelt und sie aus dem land
treibt
dieser nobelpreis ist ein starkes
zeichen für pressefreiheit in russland
und weltweit
für österreichs kanzler kurz wird es
täglich enger jetzt fordert nicht nur
die opposition seinen rücktritt sondern
auch sein grüner koalitionspartner
es sei klar dass so jemand nicht mehr am
2 am mittwoch war bekannt geworden dass
gegen kurz und enge mitarbeiter
ermittelt wird wegen des verdachts der
untreue und bestechung guter helfer tag
3 der regierungskrise soeben mahnt der
bundespräsident es gehe um mehr als das
wohl einer partei auch die bürgerinnen
und bürger österreichs haben rechte
unter anderem jenes auf eine
handlungsfähige regierung
diese handlungsfähigkeit ist nun in
frage gestellt denn die svp hält an
sebastian kurz fest nur mit ihm wollen
sie regieren die grünen dagegen sagen
nur ohne kurz geht es weiter das ist
ganz klar dass so jemand nicht mehr am 2
und selbstverständlich hat die evb hier
auch eine verantwortung eine untadelige
person zu nominieren sebastian kurz aber
steht im mittelpunkt einer ermittlung
zur korruption und untreue so die
staatsanwaltschaft heute wurden neue
chat protokolle daraus bekannt kurz
freundliche artikel und umfragen in der
zeitung österreich wurden 2017 mit
steuergeld über das finanzministerium
verschleiert bezahlt mutmaßlicher
drahtzieher der damalige staatssekretär
thomas schmidt kurz sagte noch
vorgestern er habe damals als
außenminister mit leuten im
finanzministerium kaum was zu tun kommt
doch chat dialoge stellen das in frage
fragen so sind schmidt an kurz dass der
parteiinterne konkurrent von kurz vor
einem politischen erfolgs stünde 1,2
milliarden für nachmittagsbetreuung hat
der verhandelt kurz darauf gar nicht gut
wie kannst du das aufhalten er gönnt ihm
den erfolg nicht die chat-protokolle die
nun ans licht kommen schwächen die
verteidigungslinie von sebastian kurz er
habe mit den beschuldigten so gut wie
nichts zu tun gehabt und sie warfen
gräben auf innerhalb der eigenen partei
hier in wien glauben immer weniger dass
ich sebastian kurz als kanzler halten
kann spätestens dienstag beim
misstrauensvotum im parlament gibt es
eine entscheidung
hierzulande läuft es bei spd grünen und
fdp weiter wie geplant am montag stehen
die nächsten sondierungsgespräche an bei
der cdu dagegen herrscht ein gewisses
chaos ihr chef und kanzler kandidat
armin laschet hatte gestern eine art
rückzug angekündigt er wolle möglichen
jamaika verhandlungen nicht im wege
stehen und die personelle neuaufstellung
der partei moderieren wie das unter
anderem bei der basis ankommt zeigt
daniel putzen
in diesen minuten
jahreshauptversammlungen der cdu
bruchsal baden württemberg auch hier hat
man die jüngsten turbulenzen in berlin
aufmerksam verfolgt und nun klare
vorstellungen auf jeden fall will die
basis die sich auf der peene und die
vielen gespräche die wir führen will die
basis mitsprechen drunter geht's
eigentlich eine mitgliederentscheidung
nicht vorbei das muss man auf andere
füße stellen es muss man breite aufbauen
und dann gibt es auch kandidaten ich
möchte dass die basis mit spricht ich
habe mich auch beim letzten mal schon
schriftlich geäußert als
parteimitglieder war war ja aufgefordert
seine meinung schriftlich kundzutun
nachdem noch-parteichef laschet gestern
seinen rückzug in aussicht gestellt und
angekündigt hatte seine nachfolge
findung moderieren zu wollen gab es
unterschiedliche vorstellungen zum vj
die frage wie wir die basis unsere
400.000 mitglieder in diese entscheidung
mit einbeziehen ist eine offene frage
steht in unserer satzung dass wir zur
personal- und sachfragen eine
mitgliederbefragung durchführen können
ob wir das jetzt machen ist eine
diskussion die in der partei geführt
wird darüber wird es wahrscheinlich am
nächsten montag im bundesvorstand eine
diskussion gehen dass eine
mitgliederbefragung abschließend über
den vorsitz entscheidet ist laut der
satzung nicht möglich denkbar ein
kompromiss eine nicht bindende
mitgliederbefragung und danach dann ein
parteitag der entscheidet etwa im
dezember ob das mit laschet plänen
vereinbar ist unklar die csu die kurz
nach der wahl noch ihre unterstützung
für laschet betonte gibt sich nun
ungeduldig ich erwarte dass diese
neuaufstellung zügig stattfindet und in
diesem jahr noch abgeschlossen wird so
landesgruppenchef dobrindt sei die
richtige entscheidung von armin laschet
den weg frei zu machen für eine
neuaufstellung an der spitze all jene in
cdu und csu die jamaika nicht wollen
scheinen ihrem ziel nahe angesichts des
aktuellen erscheinungsbildes der union
sehr vieles so glauben auch viele in
bruchsal spricht nun für opposition
den großen wahltag aufarbeiten damit
schlagen sich auch die verantwortlichen
in berlin weiterung dort hatten ja
stimmzettel gefehlt oder es wurden die
falschen ausgegeben oder die wähler kam
gar nicht zur stimmabgabe
flächendeckende und neuwahlen seien
deswegen aber nicht nötig sagt der senat
jetzt der ärger ist trotzdem groß
romanesco war die erste pressekonferenz
des zuständigen senators und des
regierenden bürgermeisters zu den wal
pannen nach längerem schweigen gibt man
sich knapp zwei wochen danach
zerknirscht
unregelmäßigkeiten kann es immer geben
aber sie dürfen nicht in diesem umfang
stattfinden die sie offensichtlich
stattgefunden haben gibt nichts
drumherum zureden es hat
fehleinschätzung gegeben und viel
planung vor allem die langen schlangen
sorgten für kritik die sein allerdings
auch folge der pandemie auflagen gewesen
heißt es
unregelmäßigkeiten wurden trotzdem
bestätigt etwa länger geöffnete
wahllokale teils bis 19 45 falsche
stimmzettel in acht wahllokalen verteilt
auf fünf bezirke 28 wahllokale eines
stadtbezirks schlossen wegen fehlender
stimmzettel bis zu einer stunde lang und
obwohl vorhanden wurden vereinzelt
stimmzettel nicht ausgegeben die
zuständige landeswahlleiter wenn es
wegen der pannen bereits vergangene
woche zurückgetreten ein folgerichtiger
schritt war heute zu hören nach
aktueller lage müsse die wahl trotz
rechtsverstößen aber wohl nicht in gänze
wiederholt werden diese rechtsverstöße
müssen dann auch mal das relevant
gewesen sein also
auswirkungen auf das wahlergebnis gehabt
haben das sei flächendeckend nicht der
fall nach wahlen käme aber durchaus in
betracht denn bis zu drei wahlkreisen
für das berliner landesparlament könnte
es um die erststimmen gehen kommende
woche wird zunächst das amtliche
endergebnis verkündet danach sind
juristische anfechtungen möglich nach
den pannen ist das nicht
unwahrscheinlich
verkehrsdelikte werden voraussichtlich
noch in diesem herbst deutlich teurer
nach langem hin und her um den neuen
bußgeldkatalog hat der bundesrat ihn
jetzt gebilligt beispiele wer innerorts
mit elf bis 15 kilometer pro stunde zu
viel geblitzt wird zahlt statt 25
künftig 50 euro geh und radwege zum
parken kostet statt bis zu 35 künftig
bis zu 110 euro
zum schutz von radfahrern müssen lkw in
schrittgeschwindigkeit rechts abbiegen
andernfalls sind 70 euro fällig
nach dem abzug der bundeswehr aus
afghanistan bleibt die frage für wie
viele der ortskräfte mit denen man
zusammen gearbeitet hat fühlt sich die
bundesregierung verantwortlich jetzt
dazu erste konkrete zahlen bislang haben
mehr als 15.000 menschen die zusage
bekommen dass sie in deutschland
aufgenommen werden bereits hier und in
sicherheit sind stand ende september
weniger als 600
in afghanistan hat es einen verheerenden
terroranschlag gegeben mindestens 43
menschen wurden bei der attacke auf eine
moschee in der stadt kundus getötet ihr
freund gerade des freitagsgebets stadt
als eine bombe explodierte
berichtet die staatliche
nachrichtenagentur
in den vergangenen tagen hatte es immer
wieder mordanschläge gegeben die
herrschenden radikal-islamischen taliban
machen die verfeindete terror miliz es
dafür verantwortlich
seit 17 jahren ist polen mitglied der eu
aber muss es sich daher auch den
gemeinsamen regeln der union beugen
nicht unbedingt hat der polnische
verfassungsgerichtshof gestern
entschieden und damit aus einem
spielenden streit eine ausgewachsene
krise werden lassen brüssel ist empört
und denkt über harte maßnahmen nach anne
gellinek
die polnische botschaft im brüsseler
europaviertel wirbt an ihrer fassade für
pressefreiheit und rechtsstaatlichkeit
in weißrussland wohlgemerkt zu hause in
polen geraten diese europäischen
grundpfeiler zunehmend in gefahr zuletzt
mit dem urteil des polnischen
verfassungsgerichts von gestern das
schockwellen nach brüssel sendet teile
von eu recht sein mit der polnischen
verfassung nicht vereinbar polen stellt
sich damit gegen regeln die es selbst
beim beitritt akzeptiert hatte der
polnische justizminister lockt das
urteil ausdrücklich so war das ist eine
sehr wichtige entscheidung in einer
situation in der eu behörden unterstützt
von berlin und anderen europäischen
hauptstädten polen juristisch angreifen
sie behandeln polen wie eine quasi
kolonie die gesetze von einer behörde
akzeptieren soll die polnische bürger
nicht kontrollieren können er meint die
eu kommission die auf das polnische
gerichtsurteil entsetzt und vorsichtig
zugleich reagiert unsere besorgnis nimmt
weiter zu sie wissen dass wir schon
einige verfahren gegen polen durchführen
und wir tun das um die unabhängigkeit
der justiz und die rechte der bürger zu
schützen in polen genauso wie in allen
anderen mitgliedsländern was die
kommission konkret unternehmen wird
lässt er offen der streit mit polen
schwelt schon monatelang seit mai hält
die behörde 36 milliarden euro an eu
hilfen für polen aus dem corona form
zurück auch gelder aus dem eu haushalt
müssten jetzt gekürzt werden fordert das
europaparlament der blick richtet sich
auf die eu kommission die bislang
gezögert hat den streit mit polen aus
zufällig doch jetzt steigt der druck auf
ursula von der leyen den polen auch
gelder aus dem haushalt zu kürzen die
botschaft wäre überfällig wer die regeln
des klubs nicht respektiert kriegt auch
kein geld mehr aus brüssel eine kurze
denkpause hat europa noch das polnische
urteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig
die eu-innenminister beraten über
erschreckende szenen die sich derzeit
mancherorts an der eu-außengrenze
abspielen flüchtlinge werden von
grenztruppen mit schlagstöcken
verprügelt und wieder zurück getrieben
so genannte push back soft gewaltsam und
illegal werden derzeit von mehreren
grenzen gemeldet von der kroatisch
bosnien bosnischen von der griechisch
türkischen und auch aus dem grenzgebiet
zwischen polen und belarus viele sehen
die grundrechte und werte der eu in
gefahr gunnar krüger berichtet
mitten im wald der grenzschutz dahinter
drehverbot ein zdf team begleitet
polnische aktivisten die flüchtlingen
helfen
wir haben keinen zugang zu dieser
sperrzone denn dort gilt der
ausnahmezustand
diese iraker kamen durch sie flohen im
flugzeug über dubai und
wir nahmen ein taxi zur grenze und
gingen rüber ein polnischer
grenzschützer für uns ab und schickte
uns zu rücken das wäre ein push back und
verboten wenn sie sagen ich will asyl in
polen derzeit kann also noch nützlich
sein denn von 9000 die im september
kamen schickte polen viele zurück ohne
anhörung das sei auch rechtens denn
meistens sei es so seine der familien
keiner der erwachsenen will
internationalen schutz in polen alle
wollen ihren antrag in deutschland
stellt
belarus nutzt migranten als waffe
schickt sie an die eu-grenze darum
erhielt polen heute solidarität aber
auch eine mahnung alkohol und polen ich
verlange von polen dass es medien in die
sperrzone lässt nur das gewährleistet
die nötige transparenz und
zusammenarbeit
die nachbarn litauen und lettland ziehen
stacheldraht und lassen sich helfen von
der
eu grenzschutzagentur frontex
glaube dass polen hier gut beraten werde
das wirklich frontex zugelassen würde an
dieser grenze beamte nehmen die iraker
schließlich mit in die sperrzone ob das
eu mitglied polen das eu recht an seiner
grenze ein held lässt sich nicht
überprüfen
in japan hat ein erdbeben den großraum
der hauptstadt tokio erschüttert
mindestens 20 menschen wurden verletzt
das beben der stärke 5,9 brachte gebäude
ins wanken
der zug und u bahnbetrieb war
vorübergehend beeinträchtigt
wasserleitungen platzten in einigen
haushalten fiel der strom aus japan ist
eines der am stärksten von erdbeben
gefährdeten ländern der welt
und jetzt sind wir beim sport und die
kompakt mit fußball nach dem 3 2 erfolg
gegen israel verbucht die deutsche
u21-nationalmannschaft den dritten sieg
im dritten spiel der em-qualifikation
2 also mit stefan kunz und jetzt der
erste mit dem neuen coach antonio di
salvo ein gelungenes debüt
in seiner heimatstadt paderborn feiert
antonio di salvo seinen ersten
cheftrainer sieg mit der dfb elf dabei
geht israel nach gut einer halben stunde
durch chorleiter einführung
u21 neuling malik tillmann gelingt kurz
darauf der ausgleich
der 19 jährige gehört zu den größten
nachwuchstalenten er spielt bei bayern
münchen nach der pause nutzten die gäste
eine defensivschwäche im deutschen
strafraum durch amri gandl mann und
legen wieder vor doch das deutsche team
bleibt offensiv hartnäckig das 2 2
erzielt der freiburger debütant kevin
schade zwei minuten vor dem ende bevor
der mainzer jonathan burkhardt in der
nachspielzeit zum 3 2 trifft als
tabellenführer reist die dfb auswahl nun
zum nächsten gegner am dienstag nach
ungarn
frankreich hat das nations league finale
erreicht in turin dreht der
fußballweltmeister gegen belgien das
spiel noch um und siegt 3 2
frankreich jubelt über den last minute
final 1 theo an anders schießt in turin
in der 90 minute das 3 2 für den
weltmeister
in der 37 minute geht belgien durch
carrasco in führung vier minuten später
trifft lukaku zum 2 0 halbzeitstand
in der zweiten spielhälfte der anschluss
durch benze mal in der 62 minute
kurz darauf verwandelte einen elfmeter
und dann an das mit seinem ersten
treffer und dem siegtor für frankreich
am sonntag spielt das team von didi
dichand im finale gegen spanien
und manuel neuer steht heute abend nicht
im tor der nationalmannschaft dafür marc
andré ter stegen das wollte ich noch
sagen ich danke dir gerne beim wetter
geht es zunächst um nebel aber die sonne
lässt sich auch blicken mehr dazu gleich
von westen tallinn marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um 10 im heute journal wir
wünschen ihnen ein fulminantes
wochenende und sind morgen wieder da bis
dann wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter es gab heute
vielfach hohen luftdruck vor allem immer
noch dieses massive hoch über russland
aber das hat sich hierzu unser
ausgedehnt so gab es nebel im
tagesverlauf das ist das satellitenbild
vom tag im norden da gab es durchaus zu
häufiger sonnenschein nach süden hin im
süden deutschlands löste er sich kaum
auf ja und in der nacht gibt es nach
osten wenige wolken nach westen ist es
etwas mehr bewölkt und örtlich bildet
sich nebel mit tiefsten temperaturen von
1 grad in den östlichen mittelgebirgen
und 8 grad zum beispiel im westen
deutschlands morgen am vormittag haben
wir es im norden mit nebel zu tun der
lässt allmählich nach und auch richtung
östlichen mittelgebirge aber auch ganz
im süden sonst gibt es viel sonnenschein
und dann vor allem am nachmittag da ist
der nebel größtenteils weg und hält sich
nur noch örtlich ja und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von 19 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands und elf grad an den alpen
das wäre die temperaturspanne schauen
wir auf die nächsten tage am sonntag
noch trocken nach nebel und dazu viel
sonnenschein bei 10 bis 17 grad und ab
montag kommt neuer regen auf eine schöne
art